-Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone's indoors watching
the show tonight, cozy.
I love it.
Welcome, everybody.
We're having
a sleepover tonight.
We're having a sleepover.
It's gonna be fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, as if things
aren't crazy enough,
right now, millions of people
on the East Coast
are bracing for some
pretty intense weather.
-A blockbuster nor'easter.
-A beast of a December
snowstorm.
-Nightmarish, major, and epic.
-Tens of millions bracing
for a powerful winter storm
that could bring up
to two feet of snow.
-Yep. When the experts said
stay home and hunker down,
Americans were like,
"We're already home
and we're already hunkered."
Yeah, yeah.
Instead of a snow day tomorrow,
a lot of kids
will have school remotely.
That's where your 6-year-old
just said,
"2020 can go straight
to H-E-double hockey sticks."
Hey.
[ Laughter ]
I got to be honest.
I'm not really looking forward
to starting my day tomorrow
by using an ice scraper
on my face shield.
[ Laughter ]
Well, here in New York City,
Mayor Bill de Blasio
said that while street
dining must close for the storm,
sidewalk dining can remain open.
[ Laughter ]
That sounds like fun
during a blizzard,
especially when your waiter
has to curl your entree
over to you with a broom.
"Who ordered the steak? Here we
go. Okay, go, go, go, go."
Yeah, sidewalk dining
will remain open
because what's more fun
than eating a plate
of frozen pasta while a plow
blasts you with
a foot of gray sludge?
[ Laughter ]
Yep, thanks to the blizzard,
millions of people
could end up losing power
or, as one man put it,
[as Trump] join the club.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
A lot of Republicans say
the power's still on, actually.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Sir, no one can hear you.
The televisions are off.
There's no electricity.
[ as Trump ] Yes, it is.
There's electricity.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] By the way,
you know we're entering
the post-Trump world
when our monologues start with
"Hey, guys, some big news about
the weather."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Feels kind of good!
Well, everyone's talking
about this.
Tom Cruise was caught on tape
yelling at his crew,
but he was basically
just telling them
to socially distance
and be safe from COVID.
Here, listen to this.
Yeah, wow, if Tom Cruise
worked in the White House,
we could have had
the vaccine back in April.
[ Laughter and applause ]
For the last nine months,
that's pretty much
how Dr. Fauci has
felt on the inside.
[ Laughter ]
What's amazing is when
Tom delivered that rant,
he was hanging off
a 163-story building.
Isn't that amazing?
[ Laughter ]
But actually, this isn't
the first time a celebrity
has been caught ranting
about something
that has turned out
to be pretty helpful advice.
Check out some of these
other examples.
Helpful, helpful,
helpful advice.
We're submitting that
for the Emmys show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it's been
a tough week for President Trump
and it keeps getting worse.
Now, his next-door neighbors
at Mar-a-Lago are saying
they don't want him
to live there
after he leaves the White House.
Neighbors are like,
"This is a classy area.
We can't be associated
with a one-term president."
[ Laughter ]
New York doesn't want him.
Mar-a-Lago doesn't want him.
Man, one minute you're waking up
in the White House,
next, you're waking up
next to Lou Dobbs,
whispering, "I made us coffee."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not surprised nobody wants
Trump living next door.
Most neighbors ask
to borrow some sugar.
Trump's like,
"Can I borrow $400 million?"
It would be ironic, though,
if Trump does move there
and then his neighbors
build a giant wall next to him.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying.
We'll pay for it.
[ Laughter ]
Changing gears here, I saw that
IKEA is now selling tiny homes
starting around $47,000.
Yeah, it sounds interesting,
but I'm not sure if I want
to live in a house I assembled
with an Allen wrench.
[ Laughter ]
You know that uneasy feeling
when you're done
building a dresser
and there's like
three extra pieces?
Now picture that with a house.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
In a new study,
45% of people
working remotely admitted
they drink during the work day,
as opposed to the other 55%
who still do it
but didn't admit it.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, there's also
another survey
that found that college kids
are actually drinking
less during the pandemic.
Turns out it's not that fun
to do a keg stand
when the people holding your
legs are your mom and dad.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a documentary filmmaker
made a little mistake
while he was flying over Brazil.
Watch this.
-A documentary filmmaker
got a little careless
while snapping pictures
from a small plane over Brazil.
His iPhone 6S slipped out
of his hand
and plunged 1,000 feet
to the ground,
and it recorded the entire
15-second fall.
-Thanks to GPS, he found
that phone the next day,
still charged with only a crack
in the protective screen.
-Get out of here!
-What?
-That's crazy.
I mean, who the hell still
has an iPhone 6?
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
His iPhone only had one crack
after falling 1,000 feet.
Meanwhile, I dropped mine
in the parking lot.
Looks like a monster truck
drove over it.
What a show we have
for you tonight.
Joining us in studio, she stars
in the new animated Pixar film,
"Soul" -- Tina Fey is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tina Fey!
Plus, she directed, produced
and co-wrote
the upcoming film
"Wonder Woman 1984."
Patty Jenkins is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got great music,
my friend upstate,
my friend "Q-Ball,"
Shawn Quinlan upstate,
was telling me
all the music he was into.
He's like, "Have you heard
this kid, Marcus King?"
Do you know Marcus King?
-I'm still tripping
off of Q-Ball.
[ Laughter ]
Is that his real name?
-That's his real name.
-Does he know
you call him Q-Ball?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I call him
a bunch of, like, fun,
friend nicknames.
-What's he call you?
[ Laughter ]
-Jim.
It's not Jimmy.
-"Hey, Jimothy, what's up, man?
It's Q-Ball."
-No, Jimothy is --
Some people call me Jimothy.
But no, he -- we're
straight up -- Jim he calls me.
Yeah, which is kind of
a fun nickname.
-Straight up Jim.
-You know, Quinlan
is his last name.
-Oh, okay.
-So he's Q-Ball.
-Yeah, Q-Ball.
-Shawn. Shawn Quinlan.
Quinlan, Q-Ball.
I call him Shawn. I call him Q.
[ Laughter ]
-He doesn't know
you call him Q-Ball.
-Yeah.
-He answers the phone.
He's like, "Hello?" You're like,
"Hey, Q-Ball, what's up?
It's J-Jim."
He's like, "What?"
-I don't say it's J-J-Jim.
I say it's Jim.
I know who it is if I'm calling.
-Okay. Cool.
-Yeah.
You kind of hesitated a little
bit when you said my name.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
No, I know my name.
-Alright, alright, Jim-Ball.
-Jim-Ball is not a thing
that no one --
[ Laughter ]
-It'll catch on.
-It won't catch on.
I don't want it to catch on.
I want Jimmy. James is my name.
I used to go by Jim
all the time.
Then I like Jimmy Fallon,
then my rap name
was Colgate for a while.
[ Laughter ]
-I think I can guess why.
-The toothpaste.
-I mean, extra fresh,
I don't know.
-Oh, man, I wish
I thought of that.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Oh, damn!
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, are you
going back in time?
-Yeah. I never thought that.
That's actually good.
My rhymes weren't that good.
-Extra fresh.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, I'm talking to Q-Ball.
I go, "What's up?
What are you listening to?"
He goes,
"Check out Marcus King."
This dude shreds.
He's got a great voice.
I love it. Get ready.
You're going to love this guy.
Marcus King
is on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, I watched "Soul" over
the weekend, the Pixar movie,
Tina Fey, Jamie Foxx --
they're both fantastic in it.
The movie's great, man. Oh, man.
Guess whose first voice
or second voice you hear
in the whole thing.
-My boy Q-Ball.
[ Laughter ]
-Q-Ball! Questlove! Yeah!
Q-Ball! That's right, Questlove!
-Q-Ball! Q-Ball!
-[ Laughing ]
You call him Q-Ball?
-Yeah, man.
[ Laughter ]
-Questlove is in "Soul."
Here he is as Curly.
Look at this.
-And I'm bald-headed.
-You're like a cue ball.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're bald
as a cue ball.
Curly -- Quest,
you are fantastic in this.
-Thank you.
-I heard your voice.
I knew we talked about
this months ago,
and you said you're in this,
but you're really good in this.
-Thank you.
When they called me to --
When they pitched it to me,
I thought they just wanted
recommendations for music
because it was like
an 11-minute pitch.
I'm like, "Who gives
an 11-minute pitch for music?"
-Yeah, I'll figure it out.
-I was like, well, yeah,
I can recommend some people.
And they're like,
"No, you're in it."
-Wow!
-I just fell out, like...
-It's wild. I mean,
the movie is a trip, man.
It's really amazing.
You forget you're watching --
I mean,
the animation is just amazing.
But it's great. It's moving.
But, dude, you're perfect.
-It's really for adults, though.
It's for adults.
-I watched it with my girls.
They dug it. They liked it.
-But you felt that
a little bit more, didn't you?
-Phew, man, I was weeping.
I felt it.
-Exactly. [ Laughs ]
-"Don't even look at me."
I had my kids sitting on my lap
so they couldn't see me.
-Right.
-Gosh, dude.
Wait till you see what you do
with your life, you know?
It's like, oh, my God.
-Exactly.
-It's one of those movies.
-Yeah.
-But, dude, you're great in it.
What do you think the jazz club
that they're imitating,
which one do you --
I think it's --
Downstairs looks like
Jazz Standard.
-I felt that it -- What's the
one that goes on Sixth Avenue
that goes downstairs?
Village Vanguard.
-The outside looks like
Vanguard to me.
-Yeah.
-But it's called the Half Notes.
So I thought, oh.
-Oh, Blue Note.
Yeah, Blue Note.
-But then I think --
Yeah, I guess Village Vanguard.
-I felt like
it was Village Vanguard.
-It's Vanguard, yeah, yeah.
I mean, the details in those
movies are just fantastic.
But we'll talk to Tina later
about being in this.
But Q-Ball, Questlove, Ahmir,
Questlove Thompson is in "Soul."
And you crush it, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on that. That's got
to feel good to be in that.
Everyone, we have exactly
three shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It is time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters!"
♪ -12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Three days left ♪
-That's right. Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving one lucky
audience member a breathtaking
Christmas sweater from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Now, since there are
three shows left,
let's open door number three.
[ Drumroll ]
Where is it? Oh, yeah,
I see it up there, yeah.
Ooh, wow!
This is...moving.
♪♪
Wow, that --
It looks like it's still alive,
that sweater.
Oh, my gosh.
Can we dim the lights there?
[ Audience oohs ]
Yes, flip it around.
Let's see the back.
Oh, that's what
I'm talking about.
Yeah. Alright.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
1-4-2!
♪♪
Congratulations. You won
tonight's Christmas sweater.
What is your name?
-Katherine.
-Katherine, where are you from?
-New York.
-New York. Oh, my gosh.
Can you try that guy on
so we see what it looks like?
-Yeah.
-There's no real...
There's no real front or back
to these this year.
We kind of went...
Yeah, that's the back, actually.
But it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
There should be a hole
for your head somewhere.
Look at this. Even backwards,
it's going to look good.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Ooh!
Wow! Look at that! Gorgeous!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is what I'm talking about!
Stunning! Congratulations!
Oh, my gosh.
Another round of applause
for our winner right there.
Thanks again to
our lucky audience member.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Tina Fey, everybody!
Come on back!
♪♪